it's official Mark Wahlberg has now
reunited with the Funky Bunch
[Music]
contraband contraband is funny I'd only
seen the trailer once and I was like
alright yeah it looks pretty interesting
and then I forgot about the trailer so
Mark Wahlberg plays a guy who used to be
a big heist master back in the day but
now he's gone family man he's gone legit
and tell his wife's brother screws up a
job and now he's got to come out of
retirement and go back into hiding to
save his wife's brother's ass sounds
familiar enough I know so now we have a
heist movie and that should be cool cuz
heist movies are always cool and is
contraband cool yeah you walk out of the
movie going oh that was pretty cool is
it good no there is a difference between
cool and good first of all the
characters is just fine like Mark
Wahlberg plays his role just fine
coolest character was JK Simmons he's
the boat captain in this movie I thought
he was cool and Giovanni Ribisi there's
something about this guy he has a large
range I've always said he did he could
either play a stuffed shirt businessman
prick like he did an avatar and he can
play a junked out [ __ ] like he does
in this movie he does both very well but
contraband goes from being a cool fun
heist movie to trying to be a smarter
heist movie than it actually is
it gets all sorts of convoluted this
doesn't work out so they have to go here
no that didn't work out they have to go
here and then there's like backstabbing
and it just gets way out of hand
it's like someone taking a bunch of cake
frosting and thrown it at your face
while you're like yeah some parts are
gonna taste really good in the end it's
just gonna be messy I mean they could
have cut a couple of these twists and
turns and rabbit trail plots out and
just had a consistent movie it would
have been perfectly fine it would have
been perfectly okay it's one of those
movies you get out of and you're like oh
yeah that was a cool movie and you liked
it this much and then when you think
about it you liked it less and less and
less I mean if you've already seen
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol and
you just don't want to watch Beauty and
the bees because you think it's for
babies or some dumb [ __ ] like that then
I suppose you can go ahead and see
contraband but if you don't ever see
contraband you're not gonna be like less
of a person it'll be alright you'll be
okay for not watching contraband
because contraband is the kind of movie
that's okay but you're not gonna
remember in t-minus a couple days if I
already forgot I haven't told my friend
I was like oh yeah I saw contraband
tonight and he was like what's that a
the funny thing is it didn't really
surprise me that much that he didn't
know what it was better the most January
action movies that you get fun but not
great thus ends the review for the Marky
Mark and the Funky Bunch reunion I'm
there for you guys so your favorite Mark
Wahlberg movie that do
it's done enough you got to have at
least one favorite what is it comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]